[Musique]
pourrait-on créer une couleur noire plus
noir et un blanc plus blanc des
scientifiques qui travaillent mais dans
quel but
[Musique]
laval steppas au le mariage des couleurs
des nuances à l'infini et que dire du
blanc et du noir aucun artiste ne
pourrait s'en passer
[Musique]
et la science dans tout cela certains
scientifiques en font leur quête dans
leurs laboratoires loin des ateliers des
chercheurs tentent de créer un blanc et
un noir d'une pureté inégalée parce
qu'ils croient qu'elle pourrait aider à
lutter contre l'urgence climatique ou
encore faciliter l'exploration spatiale
en 2019 em haïti allons savoir créer le
matériau le plus noir du monde
pratiquement aucune luminosité ceci
reflète le noir est si profond qu'on
distingue aucun détail
constitué d'une structure nanométrique
de carbone il absorbe 99 96 % de la
lumière
al'inverse en avril 2021 l'université de
purdue aux états unis présente la
peinture la plus blanche qui soit
composé de sulfate de baryum sa peinture
réfléchi 98,1 % de la lumière
depuis des siècles ont peint des toits
en blanc pour rafraîchir les immeubles
mais ses peintures ne reflètent qu'entre
80 et 90 % de la lumière
puisque l'ultra blanc réfléchit
98,1 % des rayons du soleil la peinture
refroidi les surfaces elle maintient la
température de la surface à 4,5 degrés
celsius en dessous de l'air ambiant la
peinture ultra blanche pourrait donc
faire économiser beaucoup d'énergie
peindre une surface de 93 mètres carrés
permettrait d'obtenir une puissance de
refroidissement de 10 kilowatts
l'équivalent du rendement d'à
climatiseurs résidentiel
[Musique]
quant au noir absolu il pourrait servir
en optique notamment pour la conception
de hyères placé au bout d'un télescope
par exemple une houillère recouverte de
noir absolu réduire l éblouissement une
image plus nette facilitera la recherche
d'exoplanètes
que ce soit pour résoudre une question
climatique ou spatial l'être humain
s'inspirent souvent de ce que la nature
fait déjà très bien par exemple le
plumage de ce paradisier noir absorbe
jusqu'à 99 95% des lumières
de quoi rivaliser avec les scientifiques
ou inspirer le génie créatif
[Musique]